right well moving on apparently um the
early 2000s count as ancient history
mashable this gets me extra valley girl
mashable reports that young people are
falling back in love with the old relic
called the flip phone oh
[Music]
final sales are up
next thing you know we're gonna be like
hawking eight tracks
the latest in something called vintage
tech nostalgia where young people dig up
your old favorites and they act like
they're brand new so they're buying old
motorola razors old samsung flip phones
and hooking them up and using them yeah
um rossie did you ever have like i had
this exact pink razor do you guys
remember this one
i feel like this is my old one i never
had one of these either you did what did
you have well the truth of the matter is
is i avoided cell phones for many years
really why
i wasn't ready for them and i had a
blackberry
um and i liked the typing i liked the
keypad this was like i want to say hello
and have to press 59 buttons
yes i just type i'm a typer i'm a writer
so i love the blackberry
this was the most miserable thing to
text on but the thing i loved about a
flip phone was this moment right when
you were like well tiffany i never liked
you and then
slap it down
do you think if they if they started
like me remaking these would you ever
consider it well the thing that's coming
out of it that's a benefit is that
people aren't like constantly on the
internet oh yeah and this is a lo-fi way
to cut down on your screen time
try to get uber on this and then call me
all right
or don't call me
because all right thank you next it's
time for us to review whatever you want
us to in drew's reviews
[Music]
oh my god i forgot about this
i feel like i've staked my teeth i know
i kind of keep i can't stop thinking
about the steak though i know and like
okay
okay today it's an invention called the
headache hat submitted by barbara
connolly
okay wait i just it's i just want to say
what's in here is like frozen tubes of
like um i don't know i don't know but
it's frozen and it's cold and i am lit
up let me tell you that
well
that'll wake you up it is literally
giving me brain freeze right now it's
like
well apparently okay so you store this
in the freezer and it's got a cooling
gel and a snug fit that's supposed to
give you some headache relief does this
feel good too right now it hurts so bad
so bad
because i don't have a headache right
now it it's yeah but i'm going to save
it for the next time i do rossi do you
want to rate it with stars how many like
i don't even think right now
um i think well i can see how this would
help if you were
in
severe pain and needed to numb your head
so you can't feel anything
if this helps it's a five star out of
five for me yeah absolutely right i will
say that um whenever i get really
stressed out in life um i get really bad
like crippling migraines
at one point i was sleeping with a night
guard and a neck guard i mean it was
like so sexy huh by the way i was like
yo all i got alone
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it a day
[Music]